uh hey everyone this is steve weintraub
editor-in-chief of collider and i am
here in the collider supper suite
talking to the cast of bros uh i really
want to start with a sincere
congratulations i saw a lot of tiff
movies before i got here and yours was
one of my favorites oh thank you thank
you i think it's going to play like a
rock concert tonight um i i listen i
have a million questions but talk a
little bit about this is like a
watershed moment in hollywood this movie
and i'm so happy that you guys are here
to help promote it and for us to talk
about it can you sort of talk a little
bit about what it means to each of you
being part of something like this that
really is opening the door you know what
i mean
um
eve do you want to go first
um
yeah it's uh
it's very exciting i um
i mean it's an entirely lgbtq cast which
is really i guess a first and um
it's also just a cast that is like on
the top of their game and everybody is
so good and so
i hope that it um i hope we're
celebrated for that as well
well for me it's an it's an amazing
thing to be uh a part of history because
i'm like always finding myself in a
place of
creating history and this is a historic
moment for lgbtqia and all the other
letters out there that you can't
pronounce damn it
and it's just that we're we're here and
we're representing
um each facet each each area of our
community and the the cast is lbgt the
crew is lbgt
you know the jobs are all lbgt honey we
we we're here where queer [ __ ] get used
to it
was i not supposed to say [ __ ] you can
say anything you want okay um it's
it's very dreamy
i am from
i'm from the south i'm from atlanta
georgia right a bible belt state in the
in the u.s
and
i've seen a lot of
influences of lgbtq characters
in film
when i was growing up but it was all
always played by our straight
counterparts and it was always in a
comedic type of way
and so to have this moment and to share
the screen with an all lgbtq cast of
every line and of every hue
where the
base of the story is about love and not
just the comedic part because we've
always served as a comedic relief but
this time people get to see how we
actually feel right and how we serve so
much purpose in the movie with telling
our our historical facts about who we
are where we come from um it's it's
dreamy yeah it is dreaming it is
definitely a historical moment
absolutely i'm gonna have to agree with
that and this is my 31st year in
television and film and
i never
thought that this
would happen i mean yeah i've played
every
the butch dyke the biker at the the barb
that's also a lesbian the biker at the
bar that's also the dyke i mean every
every word that you could imagine can we
say dyke yeah yeah yes can we say
bulldogs i'm saying it
and uh
wait let off
let me get to this rope it sister
this is what it was like yeah um
but it's like um amanda bears who's also
in the movie i worked with her on
married with children back in 94 95 and
i mean she was one of the first women
that was
openly gay and
we talked about it a few months ago when
we had a screening of this and it was
like
we just both were like i'd never
imagined this happening and the fact
like um ts and has said that you know
every facet of well every color on that
rainbow flag i feel was represented and
represented very well and with the
utmost respect like lawrence said miss
lawrence said it wasn't like the joke
it was
you know
real life real people real problems
you know
yeah so it's it's overwhelming and it's
taken 31 years to finally see something
like that to where it's celebrated and
not like a
blow by where you you know it's just
it is it is what it is and we are who we
are and we're goddamn proud that's right
i'll i'll add to that but i've already
said eloquently but i do think that you
know especially where we find ourselves
today you know with lots of
uh
uh
just a lot of people talking and very
loud but not listening for us to be able
to be up on that screen but not just in
as
entertainment but billy and along with
nick found a way to put history into it
and make it entertaining but also just
tell a story of love which i think at
the at the core root of is is all of us
cheering on each other despite our
differences in our fighting in the in
the museum we we want the best for each
other so i think i think just on a grand
scale certainly with where we are
as a country right now beyond our
borders this is the type of movie that
we need up on the screen yeah to remind
people uh just
who we are and
and and entertain and oh my i'm just
drifting off but we get it
we don't have to retake that
i think the most important thing though
that for for people to know or to
understand is that this is just like a
great movie that happens to
have
this
diversity and do talking you know what i
mean like but if this movie wasn't so
good i think it would be like i just
went off on a [ __ ] rail there but
like i'll edit that out i'm just saying
the movie's really good and i think
that's gonna be the driving force of
what gets people in the theater it's a
legitimately heartfelt and funny movie
yeah and it's it's being done with
authenticity and sincerity you know yeah
and it feels like a very kind of classic
romantic comedy like new york and you
know there's all these great characters
coming in and out i mean it
feels like a comedy and romantic comedy
we haven't seen in a while to me you
know we've never seen a romantic comedy
like this
not not from um yeah honestly never
never you know um that again one of the
reasons i'm so happy you guys are here
to talk about it so you made this film i
believe in like 34 days not a lot of
time to to film it wasn't that many like
maybe it was less i have no idea
well i'm always curious so you're
looking at the script you know what's
coming up for each of you what's like
the the night before what was the night
before during the shoot that you were
the most in your head thinking about the
next day's performance and what you
needed to deliver on screen did that
happen to you at all well i want to
answer that first okay honey the most
important thing i was like [ __ ] don't
[ __ ] your lines up girl cause everybody
gonna be looking at you don't [ __ ] up
them lines girl
and so i was like it's a mirror mantra
yeah and i went right in the boardroom
and [ __ ] up my lines but then what i
did find out about everybody in the
boardroom is that we all mess our lines
up and we were all there and we all
helped each other we were we all were a
family and i didn't know that walking
into
the first day of
shooting that these people will become
like my extended family like that i love
everybody sitting on this 100
yep like
really for real
i whip a [ __ ] ass about this
i would say that
that one
piercing moment while we were shooting
was
the night before we shot the
galaxy
and the
when the exhibit actually opened because
in my mind i knew like wanda has this
whole moment where she delivers his
speech or whatever and in my mind i'm
like
what if this really happens in real life
you know what if this happens off the
screen and which i believe that it will
that we and we will be the ones
responsible for bringing our history
into an iconic museum and creating our
own exhibit in an iconic museum and so
what was going through my head in
preparation
was
what maddie said don't [ __ ] it up
because this will be the seed that is
planted for the manifestation of what's
going to happen after this movie
absolutely absolutely
i remember
sorry
i'm gonna say we did all of our scenes
in like uh
three days i mean not all of our scenes
but the boardroom scenes yeah but that
was our we started with that which is
obviously the heavy lifting as far as
like lines i would say that but i think
it's just the the normal stress of
coming to
shoot a group scene which is already
supposed to have all these people with
all this history and to come in at a ten
as far as arguing
and the beauty of getting to shoot and
the hard part about shooting in a circle
is you're going to be doing this a lot
so i think the the joy of it was finding
new stuffs and new moments and all that
kind of stuff but i think it's for me it
was just the first day knowing
uh this is billy's journey you know with
this script for however long it took for
him and nick to get to the screen and
here we are you know bringing that to
life and that's always the pressure you
take upon yourself
and i remember um
you know we had a zoom meeting before we
filmed so i like we met the cast and so
like before we did those boardroom
scenes i was like okay we have like
a lot of icon
icons in the room you know like we have
like like everyone kind of comes from a
different world but everybody is
like
an extremely gifted performer i mean
like jim does is from like the world of
the groundlings and like dot is like a
television legend
madison
has like 90 seconds in a camera phone
and it goes viral for like years you
know like miss lawrence's
miss lawrence i mean it was just sort of
like everybody came from a different
world and so i just remember thinking
like okay you really better bring it and
like um
and we had and also nick told me that
you know we were going to be improving a
bunch and so there was a lot of like
i mean we went off on so many tangents
during those scenes that was so fun
so much fun like like like you guys have
no idea
uh they can take the outtakes of this
movie and put a whole comedy thing
together
like we had so much
freaking fun it would be the bros comedy
special yeah director's cut yes yeah
director's cut yeah like three yeah
like what eve was saying about everybody
in the room
we had so much fun and in a sense we
were there
for ourselves to represent
and also to support our family members
because
i this is family right here yeah yeah
and it's our chosen family but it's also
our family family and um i think going
around the room like jim was saying you
know you have to shoot at all these
different angles and stuff that only
helped
with the fluidity and getting it going
and and just the flow and how it meshed
together and yeah it was crazy chaotic
but
it was so amazing to be a part of that
and to be a part of what billy and nick
have done it's unbelievable yeah um i
could ask you another 50 questions but i
have to rap due to
the scheduling of tiff i'm just going to
say a sincere thank you for coming in
and i really hope this film is a huge
hit thank you for making it and
everything that went with it i really
appreciate it